-Today is Friday and that's
usually when I catch up
on some personal stuff.
I check my inbox,
I return some emails,
and, of course,
I send out thank-you notes.
[ Cheering and applause ]
And I was just running
a bit behind.
I was just wondering,
if you guys don't mind,
can I write out my weekly
thank-you notes right now,
for you guys that are here?
[ Cheering and applause ]
Appreciate that.
James, can I get some
thank-you note writing music,
please?
[ Playing tender tune ]
[ Laughter ]
-Wow. Looks like Smooth --
-Smooth Jeffrey, yeah, he does,
a little bit.
[ Laughter ]
-Smooth Jeffrey?
-Yeah, I know. Smooth Jeffrey.
[ Laughter ]
-He's wearing
the wrong pants, though.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Thank you, Apple,
for officially
discontinuing the iPod.
Or, as it's also known,
going to the big junk drawer
in the sky.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I still got mine.
-Yeah.
It's not charged?
-No.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Thank you, Subway announcing
they're facing a meat shortage,
for making every Arby's ad
feel like a ransom note.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"What does it say?"
It says, "We have the meats."
[ Laughter ]
-[ Baritone ]
We have the meats.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, new trailer
for "Avatar" 2,
for showing us
what it would look like
if the Smurfs got really
into CrossFit.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Hoo hoo hoo!
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Thank you, estate sales,
for being a classy way to say,
"Who wants to buy
some haunted furniture?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, sushi,
for not being called
Fish Roll-Ups. Oh, that's --
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's an option.
-Yeah.
-It's an option.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, Boston Celtics,
for having a logo that says,
"The key to being good
at basketball is
smoking, using a cane,
and having a beer belly."
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, Friday the 13th,
or, as millennial
Jason Voorhees calls you,
Fri-yay the 13th.
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Thank you --
I'm sorry, Higgins.
I heard you laughing.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughing helplessly ]
-Oh!
Oh!
We got it.
[ Laughter ]
Oh.
La la la la.
-Did you say you saw something?
-Yes. I saw something.
[ Laughter ]
Millennials, so he's like --
-Yeah, yeah, Fri-yay.
He says, "Fri-yay the 13th,"
right?
-Yeah, so he has like
a skateboard,
a backwards baseball hat.
-Jason Voorhees, yeah,
he's got a back--
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
He's got a skateboard, too.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Thank you, garden hoses,
for having two speeds --
barely trickling
or Hurricane Harper.
It's like, "Wow!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
Thank you, cocktail shakers,
for being maracas
for alcoholics.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Hey, there you have it.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Those are my "Thank You Notes."